Dead Island 2 is a game where as our
reviewer Mark Delaney put it quote every
single enemy in the game exists like the
world's grossest onion with each layer
able to be peeled via Katana Mallet or
anything else you'll equip which I'd
love to show you and can after about 30
seconds so YouTube doesn't flag our
video it's also a game with some deeper
sandbox elements and plenty of things
you didn't know you could do so let's
get into it
ha
if you're planning on playing Dead
Islands 2 with a friend and many of the
encounters do feel balanced for Co-Op
know that you can only join the game of
someone either very close to or behind
where you are in the story if you get
way ahead you can expect to be taken
back to earlier in the story to play
with others the higher level player will
have their damage output lowered so as
not to be op
Dead Island 2 has your classic loot
system with greens blues purples and at
the very end oranges as a matter of fact
the game throws the bulk of its named
and unique weapons and weapon mods at
you in the latter part of the game so
use whatever you want to have fun and
then worry about crafting more toward
the end and yes the game places you back
in the world with more to do after the
story missions conclude you won't miss
out
every zombie movie ever drills into its
audience to go for the head and while
that has its place in some situations
here it's far better to go for the legs
that's because the game spawns zombies
around you constantly and they tend to
group up or push on You In Waves most do
not go down instantly with headshots but
going for the legs will put them on the
ground where they are far easier to
manage
there's a wide array of things in the
environment that react to elements like
fire electricity acid and water before
you start a fight have a quick look at
what's around you poking a pool of water
on the ground with an electric weapon
will conduct electricity across the
entire surface pouring gasoline under
locked gate will let you barbecue
zombies on the other side before going
in dumping water on acid will dilute it
and allow you to pass you can even use
zombies to harm others a crush's AOE
attack can damage lesser enemies and
grenade strapped zombies can detonate
and kill others nearby keep in mind that
Elemental based zombies are immune to
the thing already on them like fire
zombies that shrug off fire attacks and
so on
curveballs are the game's throwable
items you can find through blueprints or
buy from vendors always always check
vendor inventories they can be used in
really fun ways like hitting a zombie
with a sticky bomb and then drop kicking
them into their besties
the SIM can be done with meat bait also
good for just Gathering zombies in one
spot allowing you to run on by
throwing stars are especially effective
finishes in a fight cam bombs can put
out zombies on fire making them slightly
less dangerous if things are going
really sideways grab your trusty pole
arm and get onto the roof of a vehicle
this is like zombie 101 just watch out
as Runners can climb on top of some
vehicles too
early in the game you have the option to
equip block or Dodge we absolutely
recommend Dodge even just two or three
zombies can be fatal if you're not
careful get used to dodging and
isolating enemies stay on the outside of
groups you'll find plenty of resting
zombies around the map and they promise
not to bother you if you don't bother
them there are a few puzzles in the game
that need you to Chuck something at
something and since guns don't show up
till later on have a few disposable
weapons in your inventory for this
purpose the game's crafting bench is
very versatile with the ability to mod
repair and bring weapons up to your
level the repair and bringing weapons to
your level parts cost cash the amount is
displayed here you get cash by selling
weapons to vendors or collecting it in
the environment modding weapons takes
crafting resources also found in the
environment or gained from breaking down
weapons later on weapons start to have
permanent locked perks so even if you
have multiple of the same weapon check
out their locked perks before breaking
them down or selling them later in the
game weapon mod blueprints will require
more and more specific ingredients that
come from specific zombies that means
you can largely avoid regular zombies
who will only degrade your weapons the
map will show you where some of these
are likely to show up but a few that
gave us trouble are to get insect larvae
from the Swarm Walkers flammable liquid
from Inferno crushes and electrified
brains from voltaic screamers
ingredients can be tracked from this
menu at the workbench you can also check
the zombpedia in the pause menu and find
the craft lifting Parts dropped by any
zombie type in the game if you remember
one thing it's to buy fuses from Traders
every chance you get they are a bit
spendy in the early game at 1500 each
but they open locked caches that contain
a ton of Loot and it doesn't take too
long before fifteen hundred dollars is
merely Pocket Change just because
something tells you it needs a fuse or
key doesn't always mean it does in some
cases you can just break a window or
find a climbing route to get in anyway
if you really can't find a way in don't
waste more time some areas are rolled
off by the story a lot of early optional
stuff such as locked rooms are meant to
be Revisited later they're guarded by
over-leveled enemies that can often
One-Shot you another reason you might
not be able to find your way into rooms
is that a lot of locked areas need a
specific key you can typically find that
key on a named nearby enemy aim at
different zombies to find the one you
need oh hello lifeguard Brody some of
these named zombies are tied to story
missions so again if it takes too long
move on and come back later while you
might be compelled to open every door in
the game because a lot of them do
honestly lead to alternate routes or
interesting items just be aware that you
can never close them again once they are
opened zombies can walk through them for
the rest of the game
foreign
has a few quality of life mechanics that
are surprisingly easy to miss early on
such as fast travel you need to go find
these maps on the walls of most safe
houses in order to fast travel the game
also has a lost loot system like your
Borderlands and destinies your storage
locker has a tab which I only discovered
at the end of the game and oh look my
first orange weapon great
safe houses and areas on the map respawn
their loot constantly you are meant to
return often to gather more resources
and weapons in some cases vendors will
appear after Story beats who sell new
blueprints you friendly when people are
friendly to me darling there's more to
Dead Island 2 after the credits roll and
honestly a lot of the high level skills
and mods drop late in the game so we
want to know in the comments below
what's the best weapon or build you've
tried thanks for watching